here's one that's going around Facebook
right now I'm not on Facebook my wife is
on Facebook and some of my folks here
are on Facebook because it's their job
and some of them are on Facebook here
because they want to be on Facebook this
guy is running this thing and it's gone
quite viral
it looks like it's under Credit Karma
but I don't know if it really is or not
can't believe Credit Karma would
actually do this it's on their forums oh
okay if your original creditor sold your
debt to a collection agency they also
wrote off your debt on their taxes which
wrote off your obligation to pay false
when you sell a debt to someone else if
you owe me $10,000 and I want to sell
that 10,000 our obligation to George now
you owe Jorge $10,000 I did not write it
off on my taxes if I took a loss on it I
might have written that loss off on my
taxes but it does not relieve you from
your obligation back to the bad crap on
Facebook like this is the only bad crap
on Facebook you can dispute the
transaction via dispute at TransUnion
com along with any other collection
agency owed items lingering on your
credit report your dispute reason his
contract was cancelled well the contract
was not cancelled you doofus and you can
write no contract in the dispute con
comments but there is a contract doofus
I have cleared thousands off my own
report and I've been working to help my
friends and family do the same for free
peace and love to all knowledge is power
well if knowledge is power if it's
accurate but you doofus this is not
accurate
you cannot just write contract cancel if
you could do that you could just send
your mortgage company a little letter
that says contract cancelled you would
no longer owe your mortgage that's the
dumbest but thing I've ever heard in my
life
did you never even take a general
business course much less a B law class
of any kind you people run around
practicing what we call street law which
is stupid mythology
practicing law on Facebook need to stop
so here's the thing here's the scary
thing 205 people found this helpful
course you have to rank everything on
Facebook right it's not helpful it's
completely false
you cannot just write on a debt disputed
and it goes away magically that's a
bunch of crap
you still owe you still sign the
contract with MasterCard you still went
to the hospital and got the medical
procedure done so you still owe a
medical bill you just don't know at the
hospital anymore because they think
they're going to getting money so they
sold it for pennies on the dollar to a
debt buyer but the debt buyer now owns
your but legally so if you try this
Facebook stupidity that's going around
expect to get sued into oblivion this is
what following stupid Facebook advice
will get you expect to get sued into
oblivion and lose you cannot just write
dispute it on everything and make it go
away it's like that scene in the office
when he says I declare bankruptcy
like he declared bankruptcy outloud that
made him bankrupt no you doofus you go
file bankruptcy papers you can't just
declare disputed and it goes away
because submitted on facebook said so
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]